[Music]
in fatal slip news
submitted by shreya Rahman yam on a
surface of a performer died after
falling in front of an audience Oh
always that stuff because they do the
most beautiful but very highly dangerous
Acrobat but that's what you're paying
for you're basically paying to watch
someone not die come very close yeah
like you want you go there almost
thinking they're gonna die like you
that's what you're paid to go there I
don't think about that you're doing that
are you dangerous that they are and
you're like hoping they don't but it's
like you're going for that right to
their head when you're watching them
perform well it's like not like I want
them to die but like holy [ __ ] they're
jumping and they're gonna die if you
watch oh I've never felt that in any
other circle but literally when I was
watching I was really no [ __ ] out of my
seat because it looks like they're gonna
die every second and you just wish
really you know you'd sometimes you do
mental math right like let's say someone
throws up you do someone like throws up
you see the ball going across the court
no I was gonna hit that full on the head
like you kind of like see what's gonna
happen all the mental math is people
[ __ ] die and getting beheaded and in
the most graceful like ballet stands
Everest that's what I'm saying like you
think it's gonna happen and then and
then it doesn't and that's what you're
like paying for is like the not dying
part I'm always thinking like there's
probably a net or something underneath
nothing there's nothing you know what
though there are people that die very
frequently but we don't know and one of
the Batman's movies that's how his
parents died when they were trapezium oh
no no one really cares about robbing so
it's cool cuz I think like Batman's
parents died because they got robbed and
killed yeah but like back up back in the
circus in the circumstance tough but
then the show goes on and no one even
knows that somebody died
we were mm-hmm just drag the bodies off
and these are like a secret like so this
happening that the public knowing and
stuff it's basically like every X amount
of years like there are major injuries
where people are either paralyzed or
dead or whatever it happens in wrestling
- there's like wrestlers that have died
from like those opening stunts it's a
dangerous sport what show is this for so
this happened in Florida for the volta
show I never seen no is it a Cirque show
it's a Cirque de Soleil show that guy is
so rich mr. Soleil I don't know who he
is but he's also a poker player and then
I was like oh he's a professional poker
player that's interesting so he has all
his his shows at casinos and then he
goes and he plays poker there loses all
the money yeah so young Arnaud 38 year
old father who young I think he
contoured his abs
no no but he's still [ __ ] jacked like
you should see the [ __ ] that he does I'm
not saying that he's not I'm just saying
he he did so you can see it from the
nosebleed section
yes okay the father to young ones soul
sucks and this is a second death this
happened in front of an audience
Oh My yes right in Cirque de Soleil the
other one what is it the same show no
cos the last one was in 2013 we went to
that one yeah the one worried they died
no like a couple years I'm like damn I
start but there's so many Cirque shows
though like there's a lot all over the
world let's pick a cool and for my first
one the Beatles wanted is not that cool
have you seen any other ones it's good
for the nostalgia of Beatles music like
if you like Beatles music it's really
cool they dance to all the Beatles music
but it's kind of just like washing
people at a party dancing is that a
search oh it is Otis they barely do any
acrobats like they only did like one
song where there was a lady on a ribbon
and that's it I gotta go see [ __ ] I know
I want to see like oh if you guys like
cop
Oh blow your butthole out I want to see
oh yes Zumanity like this next one yeah
get a hearty I've never seen it
sex naked show in Vegas before naked I
don't know are they they got they got
lobby paint ah well they can't throw in
whatever aren't they naked in that no I
think they're really show ahead naked
people in it no it's just really skin
tight oh what a lie in my head I thought
they were naked it's not burlesque yeah
I saw Michael Jackson one that was
really good
yeah but it's because the music yeah
that's what that's the Beatles h2 it's
like if you like that music then it's
like great cuz it's like to listen to
all your favorite songs but they did a
good job with the dancing and everything
too and in the moving and they did this
one with the Dirty Diana and then like a
stripper came out but then she didn't
strip oh she's at pole dancing Dirty
Diana cuz my brother's girlfriend's name
is Diana and every time he talks to
Diana she he goes and he goes back into
a normal car but then she'll be like
where's that from wow I can't wait to go
to Vegas I know every Tues gonna be so
fun this is sad though because like
they're giving their life to entertain
to art it's like you died doing what you
wanted to do is like being a stuntman or
whatever I wonder did he dive from like
falling yeah so he lost his grip did
people go on dog like they saw it or
were they like oh that's a part of the
show I'm not sure how the crowd reacted
what would you guys feel if I saw that
be like good show nah no cuz I wouldn't
think that someone died I think it
depends like are they trained to die in
character I mean if you if someone slips
right and they die like and they [ __ ]
splat I don't think that's or if you if
you if someone goes like this and then
do like [ __ ] and the show is not about
[ __ ] it's like some random like show
about like the heavens or something yeah
pose that question now you can tell
someone's dying out of control it's no
my insensitive though I guess just
before you ask that question what is
what what do you think how do you think
it happens between your own question how
do you answer that no so if I saw
someone
the first way like I wouldn't be able to
tell if your question was are they
trained to do this or are they trained
to be prepared to die no I don't think
anyone's trained to be prepared to die
in an elegant way yeah going to the
military's one thing to be prepared that
you know your life may be ended in the
course of action but you're not trained
to die elegantly no one's but then
sometimes when the people are dying
though sometimes people are dying they
don't even know that they're gonna die
like for example when someone fights off
something right that blind faith that
their partner is gonna catch them or
that blind faith that that bar is gonna
be there but whoever didn't set that bar
that when they opened their eyes with a
last second they might miss it they
don't even know that they're gonna die
exactly so in that in that situation
you're not trained to do it so you would
probably your natural instincts would be
to be like oh [ __ ] let me try to grip
you know what I mean
so unless I think that it's visually
available if let's say the catching
point is below the stage you don't know
if that person didn't leave the net
there and his foot just died down here
so he's graceful all the way that's not
they're not trained to it they're just
trained to perform and then the other
person [ __ ] up and didn't do their job
by setting out that net so I guess to
answer your question no unless it's like
the scene from [ __ ] Titanic where the
guys playing cuz he sees his [ __ ]
doom approaching you know what I mean
then he's like all right well I'm gonna
die with honour and like make sure that
there's a comfortable setting unless
someone fell and their [ __ ] body
splattered we don't know that they died
so like in CAW remember that scene when
they're doing the waterfall thing and
then people were falling down bad guys
were falling to their death yeah - it
made me go whole [ __ ] cuz I thought that
they were falling for real but I'm like
oh it's a part of the show yeah yeah but
then unless someone splats because you
think of a sound it's like in them like
it's playing music pretty nice take on
this like you don't know you don't know
if people died or not and I think you
just kind of have to you kind of feel
the vibe of the room if there's people
running then you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
and if the guy doesn't move because you
they move in between songs like they'll
get up and be like that bits over did
report the yawn he was visibly
struggling to keep his grip right before
the fall my god oh my god that's so sad
but that's the life they live right
I think it's not expected but it is
something that is the bit behind every
single show I'm sure they pray like in
the beginning like hey we hope you know
we all are healthy happy we kill it I
mean we do a great job sorry that's not
what I meant like that we do want to
coach for this team kill it out there
guys oh oh sorry I mean break a leg I
mean I mean they break the leg Yeah
right
isn't that the showbiz talk just once
they kill it to like after you go out
there like I killed it yeah you know
what I'm saying poor choice of words for
this situation [ __ ] but yeah I think
everyone understands that it comes with
the territory of their profession that's
like being a daredevil and being like I
can't believe that person died there's
like well stuntmen Daredevils like
people who do high-risk entertainment
yeah that's a dangerous man
they try to do it as safe as possible
but I think it happens I know like for
the last one with the woman and 2013 for
in Vegas the cost show I was reading
that there were people like you could
hear people that work on the show like
initially just like screaming at the top
of their lungs like horrified cuz they
saw her you know imagine being that
audience they stopped the show
immediately or they try to like no they
did they stopped the show and then they
made an announcement that will refund
everybody you want
yeah that's so sad I would have been
like I want to know what happens huh
I've been like uh what no I want to keep
going I want to finish the story that's
psychotic dude you're only interested in
your own entertainment it's like the
show must go on
we're already it depends if it's the
beginning of the show I'm like I I could
come back home I could but I'm like this
is like 80%
you better [ __ ] finish the show was
the main character like that the person
that fell I don't know if whatever one
of the titles yeah yeah yeah I get it
it's like [ __ ] the supporting character
yeah it was like well you know they're
kind of the extract I think you guys
should understand Bart and Joe growing
up didn't have very many hugs so they
just don't understand human emotions
it's not hug empathy that's I was trying
to make it very basic but yeah it's
empathy I said if it was only earlier in
the show I would say we'll [ __ ] it I'll
watch another show ice but if it was 80%
in you're right that is very empathetic
of you this is what you're doing right
[Music]
what can we do folks that's what you're
doing Joe well he cat now cuz he knows
[Laughter]
[Music]